it occurred to me at that time that that
you know it's nice in the holiday season
to say something about trees are
endlessly fascinating to computer
scientists especially and uh and so uh
as far as i know i i probably never run
out of interesting things to say about
them
this is the sixth annual christmas tree
lecture
and uh today i'm talking about something
which is one of the most fundamental
problems in coding theory it's the
question of how to get uh
the best possible alphabetic prefix
codes and i'll talk a little bit about
that the the the main
method i'm going to be talking about
today is called the garcia wax algorithm
and uh i i guess the one way to
introduce it is to show you the home
pages of garcia and wax
so adriana garcia was one of my hopes i
forgot to copy his cv
i clicked on this too anyway
he was one of my professors at caltech
when i was a student there
and uh he's 70 years old this year and
still very healthy as you can see in the
picture here a very charismatic guy i've
been a professor at ucsd for
more than 30 years and um
and then um
one of his students uh
who's also listed if you go to a cv it
lists all the students and you can click
on michelle's homepage and michelle
wax um uh uh
is is a
professor in miami and she uh
uh is is well known now for for very
deep research in in areas of outer very
combinatorics so kind of
like lattice theory such as i was
talking about last year when i was
talking about lattice of lattices of
trees
and
one thing you'll notice about her
homepage is that she has a tree on it
so
uh in fact this tree also would define a
prefix code and uh that's so what i'm
going to be lecturing about this so she
must still be interested in in in trees
this was her thesis work in 1977 or
1976 uh 77 sort of
like that and um
and uh uh
and it's uh it's uh
still the best algorithm for this
problem that that anybody knows
and
when you have a binary tree like this
you can imagine that
well i'm actually going to take the
the
the case where
the nodes that have no descendants
of drama as squares and and and circles
will be nodes that have two descendants
in the binary tree and
if you start at the root and and you and
you write down a zero every time you go
to the left and a one every time you go
to the right this would be 0 0 0
and here would be 0 0 1
and here's 0 1
1 0 1 1.
these
symbols
uh
form a prefix code in the sense that if
i if i take any any string of zeros and
ones whatsoever just write down any
random string of zeros and one
um i could
i i i could uh consider that to be a
message on a five letter alphabet where
because there's five leaves in this tree
and so so i well almost any sequence of
zeros and ones uh you know i uh
maybe uh a random number generator right
but you see
you go until you get to a leaf and that
gives you your first
first word of the code then one zero is
it is a code word one one
one zero one one one zero one one i not
very good random number generator here
um no okay anyway
i'll show you another
i'll show you another previous code
later but
the point is if you have a prefix code
uh you could you can represent as a
binary tree and if you have a binary
tree it's defined the prefix code so so
there are equivalent concepts
and that's why that's the the connection
with trees today is the idea but it's
also alphabetic prefix code and that
means that if i
if i
consider that these were like a b c d e
and i had a message
and i had a word
made out of a b c and d e and then i
converted into binary like this um uh
if one word is less than another
lexicographically like in the dictionary
then also in the binary sequence it will
be less than the other so so so this
this encoding not only uh
you know gives us letters but it also
preserves the order of of of words and
that that's why it's called an
alphabetic encoding it depends on the
order
now the um
uh
the case of coding without an alphabetic
uh constraint is uh
the the the um
the main idea is uh in that case called
huffman coding
i think most of you know about huffman
coding
this this is uh
suppose i have an alphabet and i know
the uh the probability of of each letter
in the alphabet for example uh uh you
might say that's that uh well abc say e
is the most common letter for example
um and so we have
so we have weights and i typically will
say w 0 w 1
and in this type i'm going to go up to w
n there'll be n plus one weights on it
uh if you have an n plus one letter
alphabet um
it turns out to to be convenient to
number this way um and uh
and the idea
for huffman code
is to find a prefix code where
where we attached the w's at um to the
leaves of the tree
uh you know w1 w you know w3 might
appear here and somehow these things are
hooked together in a tree w2 they but
they don't have to be in in left to
right they don't have to be in left to
right order um the leaves don't have to
be in left to right order but the idea
is that the um
that that if the weights represent the
the
frequencies of using these leaves then
then
letter
letter k
let's say has uh has frequency
or weight wk
then the
the code for for k
has length
lk
where the length is the depth in the
tree so for example uh
this this this code has length three so
we had to go down one two three this
this is uh depth zero one two three so
so so uh
the uh uh the cost of the tree
or cost of a prefix code
which i'm going to call a tree
uh
is equal to the sum of the
weights times the
length
so so so what we what we uh we trying to
find is a code that has the the
the minimum cost the it
will require the fewest bits to transmit
letters if we have the if the letters
occur in that frequency you with me on
that
now uh it was uh
uh one of the most
basic things in information theory when
claude shannon publishes his uh original
work in the late 40s was uh
was
to to show how you could
how entropy was a lower bound on them on
the cost of a tree and and how you could
get very close to the entropy by certain
construction
um
and dave hoffman was a student at mit in
those days and uh
and he uh
uh showed one of his teachers he had
this construction he said that i can
uh you know shannon showed how you can
get
and get close to an optimal code i can
prove how you can get actually the best
possible code with with given weights
and his teacher said no this you know
your method is too simple it couldn't
possibly work
um
because otherwise shannon would have
found or something i don't know but um
but it turned out that uh huffman was
right and uh any and his paper was
published i don't know 51 or something
very early and uh uh
um
i suppose a lot of you know him he's a
professor at uc uh santa cruz for for
the last uh
30 years or so
um so
huffman's idea is this suppose that the
weights are
are um ordered uh
um
without loss of generality since since
since the order of the letters doesn't
matter we might as well assume that the
that they're ordered with the smallest
uh uh you know
we know what the smallest weights are
this idea was simply this you take take
the two smallest ones and combine them
into another
into another super weight uh which is
the sum of the two
and so so you have these two leaves here
and so now you have new weights um w
um
zero bar or w one bar let's say is equal
to w zero plus w one w two bar is w two
and w n bar is wn
so we have we've gone from n plus one
weights now to n waves uh where we just
did we just added together the two
smallest waves
and his his idea is now solve the
problem
for this well this smaller problem has
one fewer weight
with the same method combine its two
smallest guys
and and keep on going until you've got
everything down to one tree and that's
your that's your best possible tree
now they
are the reason that huffman's algorithm
works
and there's lots of neat fast ways to
implement it but the reason that it
works
is uh
is not too hard to
to
see but i got a cheat sheet here
so i can make it
and
tell you the most elegant way to show it
anyway okay so
so so in other words
why does huffman's construction work and
uh
so what we do is we take any
uh well
what i want to show is then that the uh
that the optimum tree for for given n
plus one weights
is equal to or or can be found one way
to find an optimum tree for n these n
plus one weights is to form these n
weights
uh combine the two smallest and then
find the optimum tree for that
and then um uh take this weight and
and and and
expand it out expand it back again
so the proof that this works is the
following suppose we take the cost of
the optimum
of the optimum um
tree
for
uh
for the small number of weights the the
w bars
and i add
w0 plus w1 to it this will be the cost
of some tree
for the original waves
in other words uh i find the best
possible tree here
and then i
so that'll have one leaf called w1 bar
well i replace that leaf by a little
subtree that has has two guys on it so
what have i done to change the uh the
cost
uh
now i've got n plus one leaves um and
the cost of that three is the cost of
the other one except that uh
except that uh
two of the pass
got got longer
um
uh because they used to be
it used to be um
this weight w1 bar at at level five say
but now it's zero at level six and w one
at level six so now we had previously
we're counting both of them off to level
five and now we not now each they each
count one more so it's
so this is the cost of of some tree but
but now if i go to the optimum tree
for those n plus one weights
uh then i then i can get even better
costs maybe
um
okay but now look at any
look at this optimum tree for all the
weights um so in that optimum tree it's
some it's some
binary trees what's yeah how does it
look i don't know but it's got a w
0 is sitting somewhere
and um
and w
uh uh
one is sitting somewhere in in the tree
i don't know where um but um what we can
do is uh
is is swap these guys so so that they
appear at the deepest level so so if if
w0 if there was if w0 wasn't at at the
deepest level of any leaf in the tree i
let's say this was w 3 here or something
like that i can swap it down
and and put w 0 here i get another tree
but it's it's better because w zero is
the smallest weight of all
and so and so uh uh
by
by uh you know
by lengthening the code for
for something with small weight and
shortening the code for something with
larger weight i certainly
certainly can't be doing any harm so i'm
getting a better tree or the same at
least the same cost similarly i can swap
w1 over here uh with with
with the whoever is the the sibling of
of
of this guy at the lowest level so so um
uh this means then that that this would
that i i can get
an even better tree or since this was
alkaline i really couldn't improve it
this would be a tree
um
for
w
that has
w0 and w1 as as
siblings
in the tree so so i converted this i
converted this tree which was the best
for the weight into one that's that's uh
maybe even better um
so it would have to be
no better because it was best anyway uh
i i do know that zero and one are now
are now brothers or sisters or whatever
you you know
whatever gender you prefer for them now
uh
but this but the cost of this tree
is equal to
but now now you see this is is is a w 0
plus w 1 plus a cost of some tree
for w bar
because because this tree
i might as well uh
these two guys are partners so so uh now
i can i can say well well prune them off
and i've got n weights and i've got some
tree for those n weights the w bars and
this is greater than or equal to the
best possible tree f
for the w bars so the optimum for
for w bar
and and so i started out with
and and i got something greater than or
equal to itself so it has to be equals
all the way all the way down the line so
this proves the connection between
optimum trees uh
for these n weights and the optimum
trees for n plus one weights and that's
why huffman's algorithm works okay so
huffman did this as i said in the early
50s now at the end of the 50s gilbert
moore at bell labs uh
raised the question of alphabetic codes
and uh
and wrote a very very interesting paper
there
but
they didn't have a a particularly
good way to find an optimum code it
looked like because there's a the total
number of trees
with uh with n given leaves grows
something like four to the n
so uh you've got so you have to do trial
and error but they gave heuristic
methods of methods that would be
guaranteed to get within two of the
entropy
and
it was very nice paper but it was open
how to find that optimum
alphabetic code
and uh
and and uh
so
um
another professor at ucsd tc who
uh let's see i'm not sure i think he was
working at ibm in the early 60s anyway
he came up in uh by 1961 or so with them
with a method that he couldn't prove
but it seemed to work
um
and uh
where where in every case he tried uh he
was able to get the optimal alphabetic
code
and uh and and he kept looking at it he
uh uh tc is a is a guy with uh with the
great commentary intuition he can he
could somehow psych out uh
things he he discovered quite a few
interesting algorithms for uh
for scheduling and things like that in
those days and
wrote books on integer programming um he
um um but uh but he couldn't figure out
any way to prove that this method was
working he just sort of you know felt in
his bones that it was correct but uh but
that wasn't good enough uh and uh
almost ten years went by and uh and and
he was continuing to work on it and one
of and together with one of his students
alan tucker uh
they they uh they fly they found a proof
uh about 1970 um
and uh
and this was the famous uh one time who
tucker algorithm
um and in in in the first edition of my
book on sorting and searching this is
the the one that came out in 1973
um
i i i
i presented the who tucker
algorithm but i couldn't really give it
in in detail i had to i had to give it
uh in indirectly uh uh and i gave it and
gave it an example of the construction
and so on and then i i'll read you this
part here it says it is beyond the scope
of this book to give a proof that the
who tucker algorithm is valid no simple
proof is known as quite possible that no
simple proof will ever be found
that turned out to be false there was a
fairly s
they cut it the proof was cut down to
about
five or ten pages in 1977
but anyway uh i i tried to uh uh anyway
it's a very complicated method and uh
and almost uh almost miraculous that it
that it worked uh um
and and in this uh
and and you know in the next page i
tried to to to present
an idea to
to prove that the implementation could
be done in order n log n time which was
uh which was actually a new result at
the time my book came out um but anyway
that was the way it stood um
and uh
in the new edition of my book which you
know makes a marvelous christmas present
uh this uh
this is one of the sections that i
rewrote completely
so now we have the garcia wax algorithm
and uh and uh just as i say was michelle
wax's thesis she was a student of
ardiano in in
76.77
uh it just occurred to me today while i
was swimming that uh that i i spent the
whole summer of 1977 with tc who and we
were visiting china
and uh we never talked about this
particular problem at that time but it
was all going on at that
in that uh right now the garcia wax
algorithm is very is similar to the who
and tucker are in but it's uh but it's
uh it's got a new uh uh
inside a new approach that made the
whole thing uh start to get simpler
still the proof that gaussian wax gave
was would have been beyond the scope of
my of my book but it um but in any way
here it is in the new book you'll see uh
now what used to be called the who
tucker out there and this and i'll call
the garcia lifetime this star here means
uh uh beware um uh you know uh it's not
gonna be real easy but uh
uh but anyway uh it's important uh
and uh
uh
the the the but the great thing however
was that uh that jeffrey kingston uh
uh
about 10 years ago so another 10 years
went by and then jeffrey kingston
founded
a
beautifully short way to prove the
garcia wax algorithm that's what i'm
going to present to you today
and and a few a few more ideas i won't
go give the whole proof because it's
hard for me to prove something from the
audience but i'm going to give you the
idea of the proof and uh and and
so that i think you'll be able to
you'll be able to follow it if you do
buy this book um now however i have to
i have to warn you that as i was
preparing this lecture i noticed a few
typographic errors
and
although this is really the uh
the third printing of the book which uh
the first printing was was in april and
the third printing was in august of this
year
uh you'll have to wait for the fourth
printing to get this particular page
correct because i just made the change
today
but but uh there's uh online there's a
ratta that you can get off of the web
and if you look for
page 447 on the errata you'll see that
i have for example here's a few
a few little things where you change
plus size to minus signs in my group
i don't know what you know i was doing
something with emacs at the time and i
got i i
copied the
i i i made a mistake with the editing so
so and then on the next page i got a i
got another couple of typos because i
was changing notation in midstream and
changing my notes uh kingston's uh paper
went left to right mine went right to
left and so on and so on so i uh so i uh
i'm sorry about that but uh
uh anyway a book like this uh
when when i'm the one who finds the
errors i it means two things first of
all uh nobody's reading this page
and uh
and and secondly uh uh i don't have to
pay anybody for for
for finding the book
um
but you know i i do like it better when
somebody else finds a mistake but i
don't like to make mistakes uh
still that this this is this was fairly
hairy stuff
now
um
let's see how are we doing here what's
the i gotta try to gauge my the first
one when you retire the first
can you move
you're in front of the clock yeah the
first thing that goes is your sense of
timing so when you retire okay um
well
now uh i think what i'll do is is is
first tell you how this method how the
algorithm works uh because
so you can see it's still a little bit
miraculous
and then i will
show you something another thing you can
download from the web by the way is a
program for the garcia wax algorithm if
you look at my home page and and one of
the things you can click on is
downloadable programs
and uh on the page of downloadable
programs one of the you know gives this
garcia x uh
uh this is a this is a two-page
program this is the whole thing just
these two pages um
uh that
that that
that does it all this is exactly in fact
uh um i have to admit that sometimes i
write programs without many comments you
know uh this is this was exactly the
program that i wrote when i was writing
this part of the book and uh and and
preparing the illustrations in that uh
in that book uh so uh if there's
anything wrong with this program there's
probably something wrong with those
illustrations too but now
maybe if you haven't seen c web programs
before uh the idea of c web is uh
uh is that you that that the program
appears in small and small segments and
each segment tells you to read in other
segments for example here's the main
program
and uh
and the main program says says you know
declare a few
registers and then say scan the command
line
2 which means section 2 will tell you
what scan the command line means and
then it says do phase one do phase two
do phase three and then you can find out
what that is so so scan the command line
is this
thing here which you know looks and sees
if you know you give a usage message if
it doesn't have decent command line
stuff like that and then it and then it
reads out in this case i i i define the
program so that it just takes the
weights w0 up to wn
um
and you just you just put them on on the
command line and it
and it tells you uh um
then do phase one is this little piece
of code here which uh you know it prints
out saying i'm doing phase one and then
it does a little bit a little loop here
uh which
calls a combined subroutine the combined
subroutine is the is the guts of the
algorithm i'll talk mostly about that
do phase two this is this this this
really
short program here can you read that
yeah uh
so if this call
call a subroutine a recursive subroutine
and the recursive subroutine is this
long so phase two is
is is trivial phase three is also pretty
trivial uh it calls another subroutine
and and uh so anyway that's the whole
program but but the garcia wax algorithm
is a three-phase
algorithm that uh
that did i say with a two-page program
it's a three-phase program
um and uh and if you want to experiment
with it yourself you can you can get
this this code and play with it
um
while i think about it uh uh the the
last time i gave at the end of october i
was talking about uh bubble sword at
random and i and i and i approved the
theorem that said that uh that if you
choose uh
by a random method uh uh
to construct uh primitive sorting
network uh uh four n squared steps is is
is
an upper bound on amount of time that
you need to to get a sorting method um i
uh right after that lecture i decided to
try and find out what was the best
possible constant i proved upper bound
of 4n squared but but the question
natural question is how long do you have
to keep going until you get a sorting
network not necessarily bubble sort
and uh and i i um the answer uh is
almost certainly two n squared i mean i
i computed lots and lots of cases with
lots and lots of random numbers and uh
the constant came out to like
nine 1.997 plus or minus you know
something so
i wouldn't want it to be anything but
but two if it's that close to two so so
uh that that that's a uh
um
you know
unsolved problem but uh kind of a
fascinating conjecture i think to how
long would it take to generate a sorting
method uh
uh
at random and uh that's another program
you can download is to is to do that
kind of experiment to do the empirical
uh studies on on on sodium network
okay now uh to the garcia wax algorithm
what we do is uh in this method
we take the weights and we write them
down and in this case they aren't
necessarily in increasing order and
if they were increasing order would be
easy no and we put infinity before and
after
the weights and now we find
the smallest
uh index
with
w k minus one less than or equal wk plus
one
so we're looking at things that are two
apart in the list and we try to find the
first time when when we get a lit uh
when we get a less than or equal
now um
we're bound to get a less than or equal
sooner or later because this infinity is
sticking in here so wn minus one is is
is less than or equal to
to infinity uh so so so there'll be some
k but uh
that has this property like k equals n
is going to work even if n is zero but
but uh go to the keep going uh you know
try to find the smallest k the first
time this occurs
and then um
and then we combine
uh
w k minus 1 plus w k so add the two
numbers together
and
move left
until
you find a place where wj minus one
is um greater than or equal w this new
way to your w k plus one and that is
um
uh it is uh
what
this is a k minus one and a k
yeah k plus one just sits out there it
might be infinity in fact i wouldn't
want to add to infinity
um uh
and uh
uh but uh
but this is
uh
and uh w uh so
so uh
i gotta move it left until it's until it
bumps against some something that's
that's bigger than or equal so this has
to be
uh bigger than uh
w j w j plus 1 and so on up to w k minus
2.
uh
anything between the place where i
started stop that i have to if in other
words after i add these two guys
together um
i i have to shift them to the left if
they're bigger than the guy to their
left i have to shift it and so let me
show you let me show you an example
and i will show you on this on on this
particular run here the program where i
started out with uh
with 10 weights
101 a thousand i used all powers of 10
in here so that the addition isn't going
to be a hang up we can add we can add we
can you know these are these are these
are 10 different powers of 10 and so
they're going to add up to one one on
one
uh okay so we start out in fact uh so we
put we imagine infinity before and after
the whole the whole the whole business
so infinity and then since i'm looking
for the smallest k i don't even have to
input the whole the whole array first i
i keep trying so so i i look at things
that are two apart and as long as i got
a greater than relation i keep going so
so 100 you know infinity is greater than
one so then the next thing is one
thousand oops
100 is not greater than a thousand and
so at this point i have to combine these
two guys so i combine them and that's it
no problem here because
there's no reason to slide left so so so
here's what my program types out it says
i've created node 9 which is 101 it's
the sum of these two guys uh as a sum of
node 0 and node 1. you know this was
node
0 1 2 up to node 9
um
node 8 maybe huh what is it
this is 0 1 two three four five six
seven eight
yeah i've got eight i i've got nine
nodes but but they're numbered zero to
eight okay so node nine is it has a
weight of 101 and it's the sum of those
two weights and so now there it is now
uh
uh and one thousand um uh
i didn't really put one thousand in the
buffer until i
until i knew it would it would it would
be uh okay
uh so then then the next time um the
next guy coming in is ten thousand again
it's uh it's gonna it's gonna cause some
combination and so it's another trivia
combination we add the 101. there's a
ten thousand sitting out here uh which i
i guess i i can put out there in
parenthesis now i combine these two and
i get
uh 1 101 and then we add the 10 000.
it's going to it'll it'll
get down here now um
what comes after 10 000 million it's a
huge guy so so uh uh uh
same deal
and that gets combined in there and then
we get a million sitting out here
uh now we can watch the computer so next
next thing comes down is 10 and that's
good because it's still less see this
guy is bigger than this guy and infinity
is bigger than this guy and this guy is
bigger than this guy but then the next
one is going to cause another
combination uh the next one i should i
guess i should have printed out here but
it uh it's big it's it's a it's a kind
of a big one so it causes this
combination now we're going to have to
do some kind of a shift left one of
these times it's going to be a little
more interesting
um
so node 15
let's see what's happening here so this
so i add this and this together
um maybe if i
uh
i'll tell you what i'll do i'm going to
write just the logarithm of these
numbers or or just the number of digits
four
five nine two six
uh eight seven this happens to be
related to the expansion of pi
now uh just
just a pure coincidence uh so so uh but
now so so we had we put infinity here
but now it's now what's happening is on
this case instead of instead of adding
the numbers together we're just taking
the max because when i add together two
powers it can uh uh you know then
the only thing that matters as far as
the the size these numbers is the it is
to take the max so i'll take the max so
so
so three
is is is less than four that's going to
cause the three and one to combine into
into the max of three and one which is a
three uh the four and the five are the
three is less than the five so it's
going to combine the three and the four
together two into a four uh the four and
the nine is going to cause this to
combine into a five
uh the so
lots of combination going on here now i
got infinity five nine
two
nine six two eight so the eight is going
to cause us the six and two to combine
into a six
uh but the six is supported by a nine on
the left so i don't have to i don't have
to bring the six to the left so at this
point i'm sitting here with infinity
five nine six
eight and i haven't looked yet at the
rest of the guys which is seven
infinity so the six seven is going to
cause the eight to uh hmm again eight
is supported by the nine
um
and uh the eight is is bigger than
infinity so the so that's going to cause
the seven to
well in fact this isn't ever getting
into the next part into the next part of
the loop so so the infinity causes this
to combine into an eight and then the
eighth
that causes the nine and eight to
combine aha
now it gives me a nine at this point the
nine doesn't get inserted after the five
but it gets inserted before the five
because
my rule is after you add the two
together then you have to shift it to
the left if necessary if the guy to your
left was uh smaller than you
all right that's the garcia algorithm
the phase one
um and uh
and uh
i illustrated on
real data
and the next page
uh well actually at the bottom of this
page here the real data i'm taking data
from english
where i'm using a 27 letter
uh code with
space and and 26 letters for the
alphabet
so so first of all it's 186 that's the
frequency of spaces
and then 64 is for the you know this for
the space is for the letter a for letter
b and finally the letter z has a
relative frequency of one and these
numbers all add up to a thousand in this
case
um
so
the question would be to find the the
best possible code
for the alphabetic prefix code for uh
english text
only using uh uppercase letters say
and
in this case uh
as we as we read through you see 186 is
bigger than 13.
um 64 is bigger than 22 but 13 is less
than 32. so this 32 is going to cause to
cause us to add 13 plus 22 together
and we'll and we should combine these
and get 35. let's see if
if the computer actually did that it
comes in here and says yep 13 plus 22 is
35.
um
uh okay next to 30 this 103 35 is is
less than 103 so that's going to come
that's going to cause the 32 and 30 35
to combine into 67 but now that's going
to have to shift to the left of the 64
because 67 is bigger than 64. here we
get so so so this 67 actually has to
slide in here to the left of the 64. and
that's what and that's the state that
you see at this point here where where
it's 186 67 64.
103 is coming up now um
uh and uh
wait
where did the 103 go
what
don't you break your legs
don't i break my lecture graphic or yes
yes this is exactly why it's an amazing
algorithm
so
so um
so uh uh
and we're gonna have to do this yeah
i'm glad you noticed that because this
is the whole the whole the whole reason
why why nobody believed tc for so many
years
yeah uh yeah because i've got a
different i've got a different problem i
moved the 67 out so so so uh
yeah but i'm just trying to figure out
what happened to 103.
excuse me
combines again so the 103 is still
sitting out there and 63 7 combines with
the 64. yeah but it's at the left of 64.
no it's not at the right it's 60 but
that's actually uh going to be uh
somewhat important and then the 103
comes out here and we keep on going okay
now here now the whole process is is
shown here in this in this chart
so uh so you see uh the 13 and 22 can
you zoom in
give that give the close-up yeah so 13
and 22 combine to make this 35 here then
the 32 makes 67 but that shifts shifts
over with the 64 and combined into 131
and so on makes this
makes this uh a rather
rather hairy uh combination
but
the the fact is that even though we
we're sliding these things around and
destroying the alphabetic order we're
getting a problem that turns out to be
equivalent in in a proper sense of
equivalent to the original problem
uh and that's the weirdest thing so uh
so so we so we get this tree
and it and and it finally it all
we reduced the thing down until we got
only one weight left
and um one of the exercises in this in
this uh
book says well what happens if you um
if you expand if you if you untwisted
everything and opened it up into a
binary tree you know and said what order
would the leaves appear
in this uh in this thing and if you look
at the answer to that exercise
it tells you the order in which the in
which the things appear of course you're
not supposed to look at the answers
um you know unless you're the author uh
now here it is this is the order
actually the space it occurs at the end
instead of the beginning
uh and letter e comes first now let me
let me explain that what's the the first
uh left most thing in the tree where you
follow all the left branches so you go
left here and you go left here and you
go left here
and you go left here and you get to the
letter e
and and and what's the right most
character where you go right and it
takes you to the right to the right and
you're down here at the at the space
so so after you untwist this whole thing
you get a
weird um
binary three however the the the thing
about this binary tree is
that um
it's going to turn out that it has the
same cost as the best possible
alphabetic code
so the binary tree that you get
turns out you can
uh
to be a tree that
that uh you know it has all kind of
branching uh goes to the left and goes
to the left and has all of a sudden has
an e here
you know and goes to the right a few
times
and
you see
actually at the second level the space
occurs
and the e occurs at the one two one two
three four fifth level one so
zero
like one two three four fourth level
zero one two three four so that so the e
should actually be here
um but but you can expand that that
whole tree out and you can figure out
the level of every of every leaf in the
tree
so you get a pattern of level numbers
and um
uh the as i said like the space was it
was at level two now you now you sort
the leaves
and you keep their levels and you say
well space is at level two
um a is at level um four b is at level
six c is at level six
d is at level
um five
e is at level four as i said f turned
out to be a level six and so on z turned
out to be a level seven y x and y were
at level eight and now you you
you um uh
you look only at these level numbers
um and you build a binary tree that
that's defined by these level numbers
and that turns out to be the the answer
to the problem
no no is this magic or is this mad i
mean this is this is why this is a and
and it's the same kind of thing happened
in the who tucker algorithm you you
started out
and you started moving these nodes
around and destroying alphabetic order
and then all of a sudden at the end it
says okay now you've got a binary tree
uh that gives you level numbers now use
those level numbers and the and the
level numbers from that binary tree are
the ones you finally use
now um
and uh
and and as i say uh they finally found a
long proof that that that showed that uh
that it was true and uh
um and kingston found a shark proof
so so um
uh this is the this is the uh the
winning uh
code for the alphabetic frequency data
and if we if we convert that to um
to uh uh you know actually zeros and
ones here's what here's what it says
make a space come out as double zero and
the letter e has four four bits to it
and so on and the average uh number of
bits per letter uh
according to this is 4.2
uh so uh well 27 letters i uh
you could do it with five bit code uh
just because there's you know 30 you can
get 32 letters in a
in a five bit code with 4.2 you still
you're saving about 15 it's not too bad
in fact it's optimum it's the best you
can possibly do for for alphabetic
coding
now
how can anybody prove that such and such
a method works and the
um and the uh
uh the actual the thing that kingston
started out with was a was a very nice
beautiful simple observation
that
that leads to um that makes the problem
start to simplify
and the
his main idea is suppose you have a case
where w k minus 1 is greater than w k
plus 1 as in our
example
he says if
this holds
then
in the optimum tree in any
optimum tree
level of k is less than or equal level
of k plus one uh if in other words if if
we got a large weight
and then a followed
step two by a small weight
then the weight in then the guy in the
middle
uh
uh is is actually going to be up higher
in the tree or at the same level as the
as this as the small guy is so i mean a
small weight usually corresponds to a
large level
so so this is the this is the the first
theorem
and sec and and furthermore if they're
equal
then in some
optimum tree not all of them
uh
this inequality holds
now this is every optimum and this is
some
so so now how do we prove that and and
that's the the that's uh a key to the
thing so let's suppose that it's false
so suppose that i have
um
a case where i have an optimum i have a
tree let's say
that um
that doesn't have lk
less than or equal lk plus one so
suppose
we have a tree um
with uh lk
greater than lk plus one so that means
that there's a
that that the leaf number k is sitting
here but it's at a higher level than
leaf then k k plus one
k plus one might be one level higher
might be two level three level five
levels higher but it's it's not it's
it's definitely in this in this
direction
um
and uh
and remember that i've got
this relationship uh
one of these two relationships on the on
the weights here
uh now
if this is true then that means that
this
leaf k has to be the right child of his
family so so the so the there's you know
the
it's certainly not going to be a left
child because then then k plus one would
it would would would be down here
somewhere k plus won't either be the
the
brother sister or it would be
nephew niece or something
so um
so we got
so i know that it's the left child and
then it has a
a sibling
which either is a leaf or or maybe goes
goes below
uh but but k but uh there's some weight
here which which is the sum of all the
leafs weights here and and k minus one
is sitting here
either k minus one is sitting here or
it's it's somewhere in this in the sub
tree so i know that w is bigger than or
equal
w to the to the weight of the of a leaf
k minus one whatever the weight is that
that that's on this half of this on this
half of the equation uh that there's
some so some tree here might be just one
leaf but anyway it has a total weight uh
exceeding that and and i have to say
that the weights are assumed to be
non-negative
uh huffman's algorithm works with
negative weights but uh this uh
alphabetical i know i think it's open
problem uh what to do with negative no i
think somebody did figure that one out
but uh it's it's
this algorithm
applies only to uh very differently to
non-negative weights so so so we the
reason i can get this inequality is say
that it's either the weight of w is
either equal to w k plus one or this or
or some other um some other weights
added on to that so so it's gotta be
more okay so here here's the idea now we
take this tree and we and we form a new
tree
that moves w up one level
and and uh
moves k plus one down
a level and joins it to k
this is this is another tree which which
has the same leaves in the same order
um
and uh so uh
uh
i can see what happens so the so the new
so this is the old tree that's the new
tree the new cost
is equal to the old cost
uh minus w because because everything in
w shifted up one
and then a plus w k plus one because the
because this leaf shifted down plus one
and then it also might um uh minus uh
something uh if it depending if if k
plus one is actually just one level
higher then k state it stayed on the
same level where it was but if k plus
one was was sitting up two levels higher
than k has moved up and we've saved the
the new cost is even less uh than before
so so it's so it's less than or equal to
this
but w is bigger than w uh k minus one so
minus w less than or equal minus w k
minus one which is less than or equal to
um w
minus w k plus one so this is equal to
less this is less than or equal to the
old cost so the new cost is less than or
equal to the old cost that means that if
if i started with an optimum tree
um in fact it would be like if i started
with with this with the strict
inequality here it would be strictly
less than uh
this would be a strict strict lesson at
this point and so i couldn't have had an
optimum tree
this couldn't have been an optimum tree
because i got a better tree
in in the case of strictly
but if i had an equals
sign here so these two are equal then i
have found a tree in which these guys
are at the same level and so so there
exists in some optimum tree uh
with uh with lk
less than or equal lk plus one
either it was less than or it was it was
equal to it could have been less than
because i started out assuming not less
than
okay so that's the that's the uh the
initial uh
the initial problem that makes that that
starts to crack this
this uh
this this
we're going to open and now the the uh
now we start to explore it by by
considering you remember when i got
these these infinities here and the w2
suppose that i
that i'm building up a sequence of
weights in which w 0 is bigger than w 2
is bigger than w 4. you know
these things are
bigger than w is 6.
w w1 is bigger than w3 bigger than w5
but now maybe it's less than or equal to
w7 here's where the collapsing rule
starts to take place in the garcia-wax
algorithm in this case we would start
adding together w5 and other six so
suppose we have a situation like this
this uh
now
look at look at the look at
what our lemma tells us uh since w0 is
greater than w2 dilemma tells us that
level one has to be
less than or equal
level two
because that was the you know
take k equals
take k equals one here
um
okay now now but now w1 is is greater
than w three so now we take k equals two
and says level two is less than or equal
to level three and so this keeps on
going and so we get nice
monotone condition here on our levels
uh until level six because w 4 is
greater than w 6.
now w 5 is less than or equal w7
um now i'm going to use this limit in
reverse
and so let's write down the the
reflection of this lemma if w
if w
k plus one is less than w k plus one and
then
in in all optimum trees
l k
is less than or equal l k minus one you
just flip
flip left and right in the whole thing
if if equals holds here then there is
there is some optimum tree in which the
same thing holds lk less than lk minus
one
and so the conclusion is that this holds
in in all
optimum trees
and l
six is less than or equal l five let's
put an l let's write them all in here
l six is less than or equal in sum
optimum three
because of the left right reflection of
that lemma therefore
l5 equals l6 in some optimum tree
okay
so so i've got
these two nodes that i was going to add
together i've got them at the same level
at least
okay this is the way you start to start
uh uh getting insight into the problem
and and uh although i don't have time to
go into it the book has
almost correct explanations uh
which uh
show you how you get further structure
by by going to the left it's saying if
if this sum uh
is bigger than the guy to the left then
we slide
we keep looking for a place where
you know we slide to the left and and uh
that that gives you the next lemon here
which gives us further structure which
which tells us about sliding to the left
and you just change the plus size to
minus signs you got a good proof and and
uh then um
what what turns out is that uh is is
something that you can see at the bottom
of the page here um
i take my two um leaves that that uh
that we were going to add together
and i move them and i and i move them
off to the left and insert them between
j minus one and j uh where they fit
according to the uh ordering and i now
got a problem on one less weight
uh because if i add together these two
weights i got a problem on one less
weight uh
which we see this q i i'm using q
instead of w right here but it's you add
together those two weights and and you
get a
a problem that has only n
leaves instead of n plus one leaves and
you solve that problem
and and now you show that every solution
to that problem
also corresponds to a solution to the to
the original problem on which these
nodes you put
would appear uh at the same level
in in in another tree
uh so so uh so so basically the solution
to this all solutions to this problem
uh
uh in in this order
uh correspond to
solutions uh to to to trees that have
the optimum cost in the original problem
and
the and after you find the tree
you can you can slide there's a way to
to keep
leaves on the same level and get a code
that that has the leaves in the correct
order and that's the solution to this uh
to this
uh thing that seems incredibly
impossible but but is actually uh works
and and the proof is there
now um
uh i have just a few minutes left and i
wanted to show you some
computing i did today this morning with
this uh
or this afternoon actually with this
with this program
uh because uh it's not it's not really
known much about the running time
of the of of the thing now the uh
it's
it turns out that um
the particular algorithm that i've got
for downloading is order n squared um
it's uh
uh it's possible that uh see as you're
as you're
as you're adding adding things together
and and moving them to the left you've
got a slide
you've got to slide some numbers let's
let me uh
you know
i've got some
i got some bunch of numbers like this
and i add these two together
and i stick them over here
and i'm implementing this in sequential
in sequential memory
um i actually haven't um
well
and after you stick it in here you have
to also check again
this might cause ripple effect that you
that that you have to add that you'll
have to uh combine some of these guys
and and move and keep on moving down it
doesn't it's it's not just like you
stopping you still have to have this
condition of
the thing being sorted by twos
uh afterwards so as i'm as i move this
over i'm i'm shifting these guys uh
one space to the left and i'm shifting
these guys one space to the right in
order to make room for the new guy so
i'm doing a potentially um
order n moves each time i do this and
and i repeat this order ends times and
it can actually go as order n squared uh
in in you can concoct examples where
it'll take that amount of time uh but uh
exercise there's a there's a of course
using better data structures so you can
you can do it the best solution i know
is to keep however it's fairly
complicated you need to keep a balanced
tree together with doubly linked list of
all the lean of all the leaves
but that's enough to to implement this
in the guaranteed login and log in
time but uh still uh
there's all kinds of algorithms out
there where where there's where people
do overkill in order to guarantee the
worst case i mean they they they they
make the program so much so so
complicated that uh that that they're
paying a terrific overhead penalty in
order just in order to guarantee that
they're going to get good running time
and uh in fact it might turn out that
it's very rare that you ever have to
move very many guys to the left or very
many guys to the right it's only in the
worst case that this happened
in fact
you know i a couple years ago i talked
about the
problem about uh optimum rounding and
and uh which uh which reduced to a
network flow problem you use the fancy
algorithm for network flow and they were
running a lot slower than uh then the
brute force algorithm it wouldn't be
have any good guarantee at all uh so i
was wondering about this algorithm what
what what actually happens on it and i
and i i uh
uh so i i took one model of the problem
where uh which looked like my decimal uh
one that's based on pi you know where
but i'm using binary numbers and so uh
and so uh imagine that the leaves of the
tree are
all powers of two all distinct powers of
two but they appear in a random
permutation that's one model of seeing a
random random data but this means the
weights are pretty spread out um
uh and uh it's equivalent to taking this
algorithm and using the operation of max
instead of plus as we as we saw
um and so then so uh it's interesting to
say how many times are you going to be
sliding things to the left side of
things to the right and uh and so i
tried it out on for example running n
equals 100 um and this was just my
random number seed so this number you
know and so uh i i did 10 runs of on
random numbers or random permutations of
100 elements and uh it would how many
times do i slide something downward
and how many times did i slide things up
and uh so it was pretty much about 13
and a half
downward per thinking and uh one point
six
or sixteen and four point two uh uh
typically on the uh coming up so if i
did a thousand i was getting uh
uh where's the total didn't get in there
well anyway you can see it's always
coming about the same uh here it's one
uh
ten thousand
it's here you see i
uh
i didn't generate this by computer but i
did by text editor
but i took it out of the shelf out of
the shell uh out of the shower window
but anyway um i didn't want to show you
my you know my my typos um
so um uh notice what's happening here it
looks like it's converging in fact uh uh
here i'm doing uh
a million uh
items and and taking a ten random
permutations of a million items and very
close
to uh uh to saying that uh going uh uh
this is about you know 1.4 we're very
close to 1.4 or 1.39 uh
uh 1.39 times the number of items 1.38
it seems to be converging to some
constant whatever that is but it's
growing linearly the minus the amount of
of motion so the algorithm on this model
where you take random permutations of
of powers of two as your weights uh uh
it's it's definitely uh
somebody's got to be able to prove that
this is that this is linear in fact look
at this constant one
one point six six six six seven times
the number of items uh if that isn't
five thirds i don't know what is so so
um
uh so so this has to be you know
it has to be true that you're doing five
so i don't know what this constant is
but uh you know but there it is maybe
euler's constant plus something i don't
know but anyway uh uh
it's uh uh
this is this is really suggested that
the amount of time you slide something
up during this process and and the
algorithm is just the one that i
described uh except that instead of
taking the sum you take the pl you take
the maximum and then you and then you
shift it to the left uh uh where you
have to you count how much you shifted
things to the left and right and this is
the number that i'm giving you then i
tried another model where i took random
weight random fractions between zero and
one on the leaves
and uh here i haven't had a chance to
look at it yet but uh
uh
at the data but uh it's it seems like
it's going uh it's it's going like n
squared because uh here you see uh
um
i i i i went from a 100 items to a
thousand items and um
uh and i and the number of motion seems
to have gone up by about a hundred
so i went up by a factor 10 and this is
not quite 100 this is uh
about you know 86
and then here it's it's not it's not a
hundred it's more like the factor fifty
um
and this is still this is this one up by
about a hundred this don't this is not
going up by that much those are seventy
so and this is uh
so so i i haven't uh but uh these
numbers are pretty are pretty stable
here they might depend on they probably
depend something on the actual way that
that this number breaks down it's a sum
of powers of two
because uh because they're because what
happens is when you have this sort of
waves appear at different logarithm
levels when you're adding numbers
together and and things start to group
around a certain uh
the ones that are sum of five quantities
tend to group uh and then and next to
the ones that are sum of six quantities
and so on so so there's probably
something to do with it i haven't any
explanation for this but it definitely
looks like it's it's a it's going uh
uh
if not n squared n to some high power or
something or other here's a case where i
took the the weights instead of being
a random fraction between zero and one i
took random effects between one and two
and uh you get different you get
different statistics um uh there uh
nothing moves down in the small case
but uh
i was getting um
again something like this but not quite
n squared behavior oh wait this was
going this went up by a factor of 200
yeah it's very inexplicable but
looks like uh
the
depending on the kind of weights that
you're that you're working on in this in
this you would want to use a more
efficient algorithm than if you had a
large large problem for a large code uh
it would it would be
good to use a better data structure than
pure sequential
you would use a large code like this if
you were for example making a code for
english but not only on for one letter
at a time but you would you would take
say groups of three letters or something
like that um and then find the best
alphabetic code
or or variable size groups uh making a
variable code in a way there's there's a
lots of different alphabetic coding
techniques
okay uh the biggest open problem uh the
most famous open problem
is is to get a lower bound um nobody uh
has been able to prove that this that
there doesn't exist an algorithm uh that
a linear time algorithm for this problem
um
the best this algorithm is say you can
with good data structure you can
implement an n log n time but nobody has
been able to think of a way to show that
it's going to that it's got to take in
like that that somebody might not next
week invent a linear time algorithm to
find the optimal alphabetic code
you can get the optimum huffman code in
linear time once the weights are sorted
for you in advance
and that is known
if the weights aren't sorted in advance
it's still it's not known whether or not
the huffman code algorithm uh is that
can't be done in linear time
okay so
so uh
those are the open problems i know right
now this this this one about the five
thirds which has to be true uh which is
just a you know an interesting little
algorithm that has a has a known
average time but uh no known proof why
it should have that average time and
then this uh this famous problem about
how what's the fastest way to get an
optimum
alphabetic code
any questions
come on there's got to be a question yes
so it could be it could be done with n
log n but the constant proportionality
was huge it was really
uh you know it was like a uh
it used to be a level 41 problem in my
book to implement it in in log in time
in other words uh a
rather difficult term project for for a
team for a couple of of uh students in
144 c
um
and uh
but but but not but you know this is
this uh another page of code and i would
have an implementation that would that
would be in login
oh i forgot to mention one another
really nice theorem and that is we
suppose you know the weights that you
don't know uh when and you but you want
to get an upper bound on on the
alphabetic code uh or let's take another
ways you've got a whole bunch of weights
and somebody says move these weights
around find the hardest possible order
in which to
in order to make a code
for these weights
so so so now we're knowing only the
weights uh
and the ends and your and the your your
uh your enemy is allowed to put those
weights in in in any order whatsoever
what's the hardest order that he can do
to uh uh to make it hard for you to do
and here's what you suppose the weights
that were actually uh you know in uh in
in increasing order w0 is the smallest
uh
the the actual um
uh the actual worst uh worst case to do
it i believe is something like this you
go one like this and then you leave gaps
in here
and then you and then you go
i'm sorry no it's w0 what w1
right now
the in other words for an alphabetic
code
yeah you're given the order of the
leaves
so so
in huffman code you're not so so if your
weights are one two
uh
three
10 11
11 or something like that uh and huffman
the optimum
code
if you if you didn't have to preserve
alphabetical order in the messages
you're transmitting you could make a
huffman's algorithm would tell you how
to how to combine these and get a code
but the co and the code would would
preserve messages but it wouldn't
preserve order of messages
the the
the um
but but in the alphabetic code you're
also saying the order has to has to be
preserved
and the idea is uh actually you put the
uh
you you you would let's let's make this
13 sword they're all unequal so given
these weights what's the hardest order
to to to achieve
to to handle and and and you do it this
way it's 1 13
2 eleven three in other words you you
write one two three four and then you
put the thirteen eleven ten
seven
uh in that order so so it's this it's
this kind of a mixed up order where you
where you take the smallest and the
largest and the second smallest second
largest and keep on going like that and
now you say apply the garcia wax
algorithm
and the garcia wax algorithm works very
very neat way on this it it adds 1 to 13
and makes 14 and it adds two and eleven
and it has three and it has it has these
guys
and so if it turns out you're adding
together the largest and smallest the
second largest second smallest and so on
and then it turns out to be equivalent
to huffman's algorithm after that point
and so the uh
so the uh
this is a theorem of clickman and sex uh
danny kleitman and mike sachs uh
proved that this that of all the
arrangements of that this one has the
worst possible uh
coding final coding length final optimum
coding length and you can get it by
adding together the extreme guys like
this and then applying huffman's
algorithm
because
on this particular style of ordering you
can show that garcia wax algorithm uh
emulates
huffman's algorithm
craig so you can think of arithmetic
coaches
is worse than huffman code
uh by a little bit by a constant factor
so it's an equivalent fancy version of
these alphabetic codes
yeah uh that's um
that's theorem m um
uh no you gotta buy this but so all
right here
m on page 445 which uh might have a
um
you know
nobody's read this page yet so
yeah you might be able to recoup the
cost of buying the book if you find it
but uh but the the the yeah there's a
very nice little uh uh analog of the
arithmetic coding that applies to this
uh
uh uh to this case in fact uh no i'm
sorry that's theorem is even more
general than what you asked um the the
the
original case was actually uh solved by
gilbert moore
uh the arithmetic coding for for
alphabetical case was solved by gilbert
moore who
uh well well shannon himself came up
with the arithmetic code for the
unordered case
that's all in here anyway
yes as long as the ratio of the weight
state could stay the same
then you get the same code right
so then like that range between one and
two and zero and one that's not true you
see if you add it suppose you add a
constant to every to every leaf
so so every leaf now has weights the m
plus
m plus w zero m plus w 1 m plus and so
on okay
now what's happening is that um
is that you're you're adding to every
you're adding m times the the length to
the whole thing so as m goes to infinity
you you the optimum tree is going to be
something everything appears at log n
level
yes
i tried the case where all the weights
are constant
and there it was going as uh there it
was actually uh there were no downs and
not and uh the ups was very small
the algorithm was very good in that case
just with these little twiddles uh
caused by the randomness caused the uh
the shifting around but when in case of
equality the things would sit there and
be very nice
so alphabetically and binary search
trees they come in a lot of applications
but two things um
that we worry about in general that
applications is that
we do not care about the absolute
optimal so much but within some factor
of the optimal and second
of um the worst case length of each leaf
the height of each leaf is limited to
reverse to a bound yeah okay so there's
there are other uh
algorithms that are that get a little
bit more complicated but but still uh
can be based on this this theory that
that that give you the uh that give you
things with bounded uh level
and uh
those are discussed in exercises here
but that you know i didn't go into that
now they but uh but when you say that
you're only concerned about getting
within that close you know in small
small amount of the of the outcome uh
it's uh
i think that's just tradition i mean i
mean really these these methods uh
um
give you enough of a percentage that uh
uh uh uh that that it can be important i
mean some some people say that you know
it doesn't matter to throw away a fact
of of two or you know effective uh of of
20 or something but but what but that's
not their opinion when you talk about
their salary
i mean you know
uh you know so so there are cases where
where people you know will fight for
that 20 and uh and uh and so i i i
i i i considered uh for example uh um
in here a case where the where the best
the best possible theorem says that the
lower bound on a code which you could
construct from the entropy is 3.38 and
and and and the best upper bound saying
there exists a code by this general
scheme is is 6.6 but then you actually
uh work through the algorithm and you
find out that you get a code that's you
know 5.01 and so so it uh
it it's uh
these algorithms are actually it can
actually give you a payoff if you you
know if you're
if dollars mean anything to you and and
you can convert this to dollar
does there exist a linear time
which can give me a not
not exactly optimum
cost but there's no recording
well no that i guess that isn't
necessarily
um
that's the the linea that you mean
for alpha yeah i i'm not i
i have to think about that
uh the um
i mean it's i i don't know if anybody's
implemented
conceptually it's very it's very it's
very nice because you just look at the
partial sums of the frequency
distribution and then you
and and and you and you and you uh uh
you
you cut off
um
but when you say linear time uh it's not
not clear when you i mean the
pre-processing
how how you handle it yeah i i
there's uh
you know i had a paper once on
on something that also gallagher had
done earlier i didn't know about it but
it was for uh for linear uh for
for uh
doing huffman coding on the fly
dynamically
updating it like
if you're trying to if you're trying to
send files by ftp or something you want
to compress them and you want to sort of
know learn the statistics of the source
as you go and so you keep on on updating
it and i had a method that was uh you
know that was that was linear time but
it needed in some cases you were looking
at the tree up from the top to down in
other cases from the bottom up and so
when you actually started to study the
hardware it was it wasn't was not
exactly clear what you meant by linear
time these questions are kind of tricky
um now next year uh probably beginning
of february i'm going to give another
talk and it's i'm really excited about
right now i'm designing a new computer
uh and i'm going to uh it's going to be
the the
computer for the next millennium so i'll
present it uh
in the next
talk in this series
thanks very much